قذيفه من قذائف الموت الذاهبه باتجاه جبهه
لا تهدا مع بدء عام جديد على الحرب القوات
الاوكرانيه تسابق الزمن لاحراز اي تقدم
لكن ما هي احوال حاضنه الجيش الاجتماعي
بعد اشهر ثقيله على الحرب منذ انسحاب
الروس من مدينه خيرسون بدات اولغا باعداد
الخبز مجانا للجنود الاوكرانيين في معملها
الخاصه اعدادنا الخبز لجنودنا هو احد
اشكال النضال من اجل ان تبقى اوكرانيا
مستقله من اجل مستقبلنا ومستقبل اولادنا
يجب ان نواصل العمل بغض النظر عن الاخطار
التي تحيط بنا نحو 500 رغيف تجهز يوميا
نزين الخبز بشعار دولتنا الذي يرمز الى
القوه نؤمن ان الانتصار قادم وان جيشنا
سيستعيد كامل اوكرانيا
لكن الامر مختلف بالنسبه لفلانتينا
فهي تعتقد ان اسناد الجيش الاوكراني الى
ما لا نهايه بات صعبا في ظل اشتداد القصف
الروسي على مدينتها محطه القطار تحولت الى
تكنه عسكريه
وحاضنه الجيش او بعضها اصابها كثير من
الوهن لقد احتجزت الحرب مصائر الناس لحظات
ما قبل مغادره فالنتينا وطفلها الوجهه
مقاطعه ليفيف الامنه هناك سيبتاني حياه
جديده
طفلي كان كثيرا البكاء لم تعد لدينا
القدره على التحمل الروس كانوا يقصفون كل
يوم ومع كل قصف كنا نشعر بخوف شديد
غير ان عتمه الحرب وتبعاتها ارهقت انيا
فلم تعد قادره على اسناد جيش بلادها بقيت
انيا مع ابنها اليكس في خرسون بعد ان شمله
قرار التجنيد قبل ذلك ارسلت اطفالها
الثلاثه برفقه والدتها الى مولدوفا خوفا
على حياتهم
ما معنى ان يبقى ابني هنا تحت وطاه القصف
لن اتركه وحيدا
امنوا ان تنتهي هذه الحرب سريعا نريد ان
نستعيد حياتنا السابقه
[موسيقى]
لكن رحله اولغا لم تصل الى نهايتها بعد
فالخبز في طريقه الى جبهات القتال والمهمه
لا تزال طويله
في ضواحي خيرسون مزيد من الخسائر شظايا
الصراع وصلت قلب المقبره هنالك الكثير من
القبور التي قضى اصحابها بفعل الحرب وهذه
بعض منها انظروا واحد اثنان ثلاثه اربعه
والقائمه تطول والحرب ايضا ليبقى السؤال
عن مدى قدره الاوكرانيين على التحمل اكثر
تمرس ماديا الجزيره خيرسون